foreign
[Music]
T I manage a team of data scientists in
Chicago and I am here to talk about
garbage data
but before I talk about garbage data I
want to lead you off with a quote a lot
of you have probably seen this quote
before it's about statistical models
it's from the famous statistician George
box and he wrote a bunch of times at
least the first part all models are
wrong but some are useful but then
sometimes he'd go on he'd add things
like so the question you need to ask
yourself is not is the model true
because it never is but is the model
good enough for this particular
application and I love this quote it's
true it's not explicitly about garbage
data but it turns out that you can just
cross out models and replace it with
data and the quote's still true
because all data are wrong but some are
useful right there's no such thing as a
perfect data collection tool or data
retention tool and so the question that
you need to ask yourself isn't are the
data true because they're not but are
the data good enough for this particular
application right and so the you in the
sentence that I'm thinking of uh is US
data professionals uh and depending on
where you're at uh whether you're an
industry or Academia the titles are
going to differ right it could be a data
scientist or engineer or architect or
academic researcher the point is though
that we data professionals are often the
primary deciders of data usefulness in
our organizations and a typical workflow
at least for me kind of looks like this
so we'll have some stakeholders that are
super enthusiastic I use a lot of emojis
so if you don't like Emoji you should
leave
um
so stakeholders will be uh really
enthusiastic they'll come to us and ask
for help like they brought us some data
and I don't work in agriculture this is
a metaphorical Haystack right
um and so then we spring into action and
we think okay cool we're on this
hypothetical Continuum of data
usefulness do we think that these data
should fall and if they're maximally
useful right like the best case scenario
is that they are just chock full of
insights which you see the metaphor
keeps going now we've got needles
answers to our questions solutions to
our problems whatever uh the
stakeholders are looking for because I
mean ultimately
stakeholders expect that there's going
to be something in data right like
that's the promise of big data and so
even if
we make this assessment that data are
minimally useful the expectation from
our stakeholders is still like there's
non-zero insights in there right like
that there's at least a needle in the
hay stack or two needles
um
and again people are led to believe that
data are always going to be the solution
here they're not going to be the problem
um
but I think Megan stock highlighted Max
Coon's keynote this morning also called
out uh
data aren't always useful and in a lot
of cases data are just garbage and
garbage data are at all of our
organizations right I think if you've
worked with real world data you
definitely have encountered garbage data
and so you know then that garbage data
is problematic and has costs and can
lead to real problems within our
organization so my talk here I want to
make sure you all walk away with at
least three points first I want to make
sure you can identify garbage data in
your organizations second I want to make
sure that you're aware of and can
identify the costs of garbage data and
then finally I want to make sure that
you're taking action when you see
garbage data
all right so hitting the first point
here on identifying garbage data so like
we think an operational definition is a
good starting point and garbage data I
think simply are just data that aren't
useful for a particular application so
if we have stakeholders coming up to us
then the first question we really need
to ask them is are the data that you're
giving us that we're working with
relevant for the questions that you're
interested in asking
and so say our
stakeholders come up with questions
about hot dogs and then they give us
data like this
and it's adorable and it's passively
useful based on the just the simple dogs
being in there uh hat tip to Hadley for
this joke by the way in the feedback
thank you Hadley
um but as we're making our decision
about how the data are useful or not
it's quite likely that we'll probably
say no these data aren't relevant to the
particular application they're likely
not going to be able to answer your
questions but
our questions usually don't stop there
right we've identified the garbage data
but garbage data aren't always garbage
they could be relevant for a different
thing so the next question we want to
ask our stakeholders uh is there another
application where these data could be
relevant
and so if you're stakeholders are
anything like mine they have lots of
questions it's not just that their
questions are about hot dogs or one
thing in particular oftentimes the data
that they have are probably relevant to
something else that they're interested
in and so working with them to find out
if there's another question that the
data can be helpful in answering seems
like is another reasonable step to take
um I think that there's one other step
to take after this though say you say no
and the data are not necessarily useful
for this secondary application I think
it's safe to or fair to ask are there
reasons to expect that these data are
total garbage because again we've worked
with real world data we know that there
are definitely cases where your data are
not useful for anything
and that often requires us to put on our
sleuthing hats which is usually a part
of any data professionals Arsenal I'm
not going to go into all of the ways
that data can be totally garbage but I'm
going to walk through at least a few
examples because I'm sure that they will
resonate with some of
Megan also had a ton of awesome examples
in her talk as well so check out that
repo
um so things can go wrong during data
collection I used to work with
handwriting data sometimes that data is
illegible this is not data from any of
my previous studies this is actually
from a New York Times article about kids
handwriting
um but the point I think is still well
taken that sometimes the data is just
completely borked from the point of
collection uh it could also get screwed
up in retention right I've had a weird
case where some of my data were
corrupted from a hard drive failure but
not all of it and it didn't become clear
until I'm doing a little bit more
digging and reading a whole bunch of
logs which is not my favorite way of
spending time and so retention is
another opportunity for things to really
go wrong and make your data totally
garbage
uh
90s kids Steve Urkel uh so a lot of
times the total garbage results from
someone accidentally borking the data I
have done this more times than I can
count and if there's anyone in the room
who has not accidentally booked their
data to make it useless or very close to
useless
um
raise your hand uh well actually don't
raise your hand because it's going to
happen sooner or later so just be
prepared for that sort of thing so
people make mistakes all the time in
data collection and retention and so
that's sometimes how data will become
totally useless I think a recent cases
where we had a lot of data that were
replaced by default values and so when
it looked like 99 of our sample were
default values we had to start wondering
if that was going to be useful for
inference
the last case uh which I think makes a
lot of news and headlines is that
sometimes people intentionally book
their data this is what I think we used
to think cyber criminals looked like
maybe this is what they actually look
like I'm not sure
um
I don't necessarily think that this is
like the most common scenario right
people usually seem to be honest in my
experience with their data unless
they're really incentivized to have data
look up very specific way so I guess if
those cases are arising which I don't
think I've ever had in my career
um that might be an opportunity where
totally garbage data could be arising
so in those cases what do you do you've
identified that the data are totally
garbage those need to be destroyed I
think in most cases I can point to a
number of times when I've worked with
folks that have tried to make inferences
from totally garbage data and we'll get
into the consequences of those in a
little while but
um if you can't put up or if you can't
totally destroy the data put up as much
warning tape as you possibly can because
you want to make sure that nobody else
is trying to accidentally make
inferences out of this
so identifying data is useful
identifying garbage data is useful but I
called out that there's a reason to do
it and it's because garbage data excuse
me I had a summary slide so summing up
part one uh some garbage data use not
useful uh some garbage data are useful
for other stuff some not useful for
anything
so
why do we care well it's because garbage
data have costs and I think of those
costs in a couple different ways I think
first of these unavoidable costs that
you're going to have any time you have a
data project right this is a just
example Cloud bill because every time
you have a data project you're going to
incur costs with data collection data
retention any kind of support around
those data there's always going to be a
cost your data Lake your cloud provider
doesn't know probably doesn't care if
your data are garbage those costs are
going to happen whether your data are
good or not
you might not be able to avoid some
costs but the avoidable costs I think
are really the ones you have to be on
the lookout for because that can really
torpedo your organization so first
the excessive regular old data costs
right if you don't catch the fact that
you have garbage data well you're just
going to keep incurring bills and bills
and bills and they add up and I suspect
that in a lot of organizations they're
bigger than 7 400 a month so
um if you can catch garbage data when it
happens that can save a lot of costs
um opportunity costs I think are another
really important one to call out that
are probably a lot less easy to point to
because like they're not tangible they
didn't happen you can't say I missed
this thing right but
philosophically garbage data necessarily
doesn't have any value so any time you
spend looking into it is time you should
have been spending doing something else
but we're practical we're not here for
philosophy and so uh like from a
practical perspective
you see that there's a lot of
interesting things that you could be
working on as a data professional
instead of kind of Plumbing the depths
of these garbage data and trying to
validate that your stakeholders might be
able to find something or might not be
able to find something and I think that
leads to another level of cost which are
these people costs
um
I like to learn things I like to help
other people learn things and kind of
answer their questions and you can't do
that with garbage data and eventually
after having to work with garbage data
over and over and over again data
professionals are probably going to go
find something else to do or go look for
data that may or may not be garbage I
guess as a spoiler the grass isn't
Greener everywhere if anyone's worried
about their organizations being
specially booked it's dirty everywhere
but people will continue to look if the
data that they're working with isn't
allowing them to learn things
and I think that that leads to maybe the
most obvious kinds of costs which are
decision costs right because if you're
making decisions with garbage data you
don't know what's going to happen right
like you're making decisions basically
with random noise in a lot of cases uh
and that means something good could
happen but not because of Any smart
things we did but lots of bad things
could happen too and that's why I think
that ultimately these avoidable costs
can really be catastrophic right so if
you think about making bad decisions
after all of your data professionals
have left looking for greener pastures
after having spent all of your money
retaining a bunch of garbage data that
feels like a recipe for disaster for an
organization and so the costs can really
really really add up garbage data is
something that we need to care a great
deal about
so now I'm remembering my summary slide
so in summation part two uh think about
garbage data costs in a couple of
different ways unavoidable costs you're
going to have those anytime you have a
data project avoidable costs though can
be catastrophic
so finally
we should take action when we see
garbage data what does that mean though
so we're the primary deciders of data
usefulness
the first thing I think it means is when
people come to us with questions and
bring us some data we have to be honest
with them and direct with them I know
that I don't like to give people bad
news at various points in my life people
have called me Jim the Dream Crusher and
I felt bad it was a joke but I felt bad
about it and I don't want to be in that
position but
the consequences of not being honest and
direct with your stakeholders and
letting them know when garbage data
happens are a lot worse than the
consequences of having some bummed
stakeholders right now we don't want to
bum any stakeholders
again I think that we are obligated as
the people who are kind of the line of
defense against garbage data to say this
is garbage
okay cool
um
so the second thing right we don't want
to bum people out uh I think we need to
lead with empathy and this probably is
just kind of par for the course for most
of us but it's useful to say it
explicitly our stakeholders have a lot
of things that they need our
stakeholders have demands on them they
have pressures on them they're not using
garbage data or asking us to play around
with garbage data because they think
that it's a good way for us to spend
their time they're asking us because
they need our help for something and so
if we're not leading with empathy we end
up with salty stakeholders who don't
want to work with us anymore and working
with salty stakeholders is a good way to
not have a job anymore or be a
professional data professional anymore
um another useful thing to to try and do
is if you can influence your
organization to treat all problems as
data problems from the very beginning
all projects should be data projects
until otherwise kind of considered so
default to treating projects as data
projects so an ideal workflow is when my
stakeholders come to me with questions
rather than coming with to me with data
that gives me the opportunity and my
team the opportunity to evaluate which
data sets might be most appropriate to
help them answer those questions which
makes it at least more likely that we're
going to find something in there and
again like they may not be as happy as
if you'd given them a huge pile of
needles but they'll be grateful that you
didn't leave them empty-handed
and then finally uh I think we have to
be patient because organizations are
used to doing things however they've
been doing them uh and coming in and
saying hey you're doing it wrong is
never going to uh Drive change I have
made that mistake it's a bad idea uh so
be patient build those relationships and
if you do all of this stuff like if
you're
I I think the third part here the
actions that we can take here is like we
have to be honest we have to be
empathetic make sure we're treating all
projects as data projects and making
sure that we're patient
I think that'll help us accomplish all
three of these points here of being able
to identify garbage data the costs take
making sure that we're taking action and
I guess to wrap it up
I mean if you do everything I suggest
your data are still going to be wrong
no matter what there is no changing that
but
there's a better chance that they could
turn out to be useful and that's our
goal so
thank you all very much for your time
[Applause]
[Music]